-So, Marsha P. Johnson
was an LGBT activist.
-She was.
-And this film examines --
tries to get to the bottom
of her unsolved death
25 years ago.
But you knew her for a long
time.
How did you first meet her
and what were your experiences
with her like?
-Well, you know,
I moved to New York in 1981.
And she was already a famous
personage of Lower Manhattan.
She was kind of the queen
of downtown, at the time.
But I was taken to meet her
because, as a newcomer,
I had a boyfriend who felt
he needed to kind of give me
a boot camp of life in New York.
And he brought me
to meet Marsha Johnson.
-So, she was sort of
a drill sergeant
of New York at the time?
-She had a lot -- a lot
of information to impart,
and one of the things she did
was that she sold
fake tokens for the subway.
[ Laughter ]
And that was certainly
a lesson I needed to learn,
as a 21 year old
who moved to New York
was how $5 could actually
stretch out
to almost a year
of subway rides.
[ Laughter ]
-It´s very helpful.
-She stayed in that business
until the city figured it out
and rebalanced
the weight of the subway tokens.
-And she -- What was the role
that she played at Stonewall?
Because she was a big part of
that sort of historic moment.
-She was. She was --
She was kind of a leader,
even before Stonewall.
And -- And people followed her.
When the --
And before Stonewall, of course,
it was illegal to sell drinks
in New York to gay people.
It was illegal to dress in drag
in New York.
People were being thrown in jail
and worse --
into psychiatric institutions --
just for dressing
the way that they felt.
And there came that night
in 1969
where people just had enough.
And Marsha is said to be
the person
who threw the first brick
that night.
I don´t think she did.
But I know that she -- she threw
the bricks in the middle.
And she was one of the leaders
of the -- of this --
of this campaign
that just said, "Enough."
Enough.
And for that,
they called her the --
the, you know, founder,
really, or co-founder
of the modern LGBT movement.
-The "P" in Marsha P. Johnson
was a nickname
that was given to her.
Can you give us
the origin of that?
-She gave it to herself.
-Okay.
-And she always just called
herself Marsha P. Johnson,
and she was -- she was arraigned
once for --
She was a sex worker.
But I think it may have been
arraigned
for other political work.
And the judge said,
"What does the ´P´ stand for?"
And she said,
"Pay it no mind!"
[ Laughter ]
And so it stuck.
-I would have --
That´s a very nice thing
to have in your back pocket.
-Yeah, yeah, exactly.
-So the --
She dies 25 years ago.
-Right.
-The police ruled it a suicide.
Those close to her
thought there were maybe
nefarious reasons behind it.
And so you sort of embark
on this documentary
not knowing what answer
you´re going to find.
How was it for you,
having known her,
to revisit this
in this political climate
that we´re living in
in present time?
-It´s -- It´s a case
that I think
has weighed on me
and on many people.
You know, the question
about what happened
to this really seminal,
central figure in New York.
She traveled the world
as a performer.
She was a friend
of Andy Warhol´s.
She was connected
at every level.
And that the police seemingly
didn´t do an investigation
was shocking
and caused the community
to stage
these massive demonstrations,
which you see in the film,
back in ´92.
And 25 years later,
I wanted to go back.
Because I thought
the time was right
to learn about the origin
of the transgender culture
and movement and community.
And I thought we would be
producing a film of celebration
to celebrate
how far we had come.
And what we learned, of course,
as our culture has changed
and our politics have changed,
is that the film is dropping
in a really dangerous time
for transgender people,
a time of increased violence
against the community
and a time
of political backlash
like we haven´t seen before.
-There is a lot to be
pessimistic about now.
But one of the messages
that´s in the film
is that Marsha used -- one of
the political tools she used
was happiness.
-Right.
-Can you speak to that?
-You see that in the footage,
as well.
You know, I think the main role
that she played,
aside from helping to form
that first modern LGBT rights
move-- organization,
following the riots,
was to -- to take on
a personage of freedom.
I mean, the community
in 1969 and 1970
was demanding freedom,
was marching toward freedom,
was demanding rights.
But no one really knew
what that looked like.
And Marsha decided she was going
to just figure it out.
And she -- she did it
through dressing wildly.
She wore whatever
she wanted to wear.
She always had this crown
of feathers in her hair.
She made her own gowns
out of anything she could
find on the street, mostly,
or in restaurants --
curtains from restaurants
she´d walk out with.
And then --
And she was --
-Were they happy
when she took the curtains?
Or was there --
-They were happy
she didn´t take more.
[ Laughter ]
-"Oh, that´s the token lady.
Let it go."
-And she likely to leave
something behind, also.
-Yeah.
-So she´s very generous
that way.
-Sure.
-And -- And then
she just smiled.
And she encouraged people
to feel what it was like
to no longer be oppressed.
And she did it through humor,
as it was said in the clip
that you showed.
And she did it through just
a joyous political presence.
And it´s something
that I recognized,
looking back
at the archival footage,
she was doing intentionally.
This was her --
This was her political point.
And through that joy,
she held the community together
for a long time.
And because she was such a great
presence in downtown New York,
she touched everybody´s lives on
a regular basis.
-Well, it´s a wonderful story.
It also sparks this question
of who is -- who should
tell what stories.
This is a story about
a black trans woman.
What brought you to tell it?
-Well, I certainly felt
a kinship with Marsha,
having known her.
And, you know, I did feel
that her story is so central --
the Rosa Parks, really,
of the LGBT movement,
who had never really been
celebrated in a significant way.
And I felt that that was --
that was an oversight.
And that oversight
is largely laid at the feet
of, you know, white filmmakers,
who never thought to go back
and tell her story.
So I felt a kind
of an obligation to her
as a friend and as a member
of my community
to lift her up and to give her
the significant treatment
that a figure of her stature
deserved.
You know, I wanted to put her
in the canon
of, you know, great Americans.
And she belongs there.
And certainly she needed a film
to show the world about her.
-Well, thank you so much
for making one
that told us more about her.
I really appreciate it.
And thank you so much
for being here.